what do you think is the meaning of life
i think the meaning of life is
um why are we here oh well that i'm a
camus person
so i'll give the kamu answer so there's
two types of people
those who know how to use binary no
thanks thanks for relating to the
audience
one zero zero one two two
down vote what kind of radical freak is
this legs
so and i use this example of my
forthcoming book
you go into a countryside a mountainside
and you see a blank canvas
on an easel and one kind of mentality
goes this is
it's just a blank canvas this is stupid
this is what am i looking at
and the other type goes what a great
opportunity
i'm in this beautiful space i have this
entire canvas to paint i can do anything
i want with it
so i'm very much of that type 2 person
and i hope others start to
think of life in that way you and i have
both been more successful than we
expected to especially growing up
and in ways we did not expect and when
you're young
you are so intent on driving the car and
after a certain point you realize it's
not about driving the cars you're being
a surfer
that you can only control this little
board and you have no idea where the
waves will take you and sometimes you're
gonna fall down and something's gonna
suck and you're gonna swallow some salt
water
but at a certain point you stop trying
to drive and you're like this is
freaking awesome and i have no idea
where it's gonna go
you